- The CIFAR Winter
School really allowed me
to see how different and
rich the approaches could be
even to the same problem on
which I myself specialized.
- There are so many people
from very different backgrounds
diverse backgrounds,
different stages of the career
and all open minded and willing
to discuss and dialogue.
- Now I can talk to people
from different fields
about different things,
and that basically gave me
a broader perspective on what science is.
- For those of you that are really looking
for a unique opportunity
to both build a sense of
community and research,
but also strengthen
interdisciplinary connections,
I would encourage you to apply now.
(soft music)